uh let's see what else we've got here
the david pakman
[Music]
so you've heard me say it this is not a
rehearsal
very very important stuff because this
could get really ugly really quickly
now
[Music]
the big big big big big question
you all see what's going on i see what's
going on we're not going to fall for it
these bizarre
semantic games philosophical black holes
that people are getting we're just not
going to bite
[Music]
i would return the ballot as soon as
possible
if you're mailing it if you have the
ability to drive it to a ballot box
i would do that as well and that's
actually my plan
make sure you have a plan that makes
sense based on what's happening in your
state
based on where you can drop off ballots
in your state
and don't make your plan on the basis of
a false sense of security from this
announcement that's the most important
message i think
[Music]
we have to just vote early early early
but it's too close
it's too risky we really need donations
of the plasma
tea and i will have to make a decision
about how and when i send in my ballot
and assume nothing going into november
every single voter i i
apologize i know i say this a lot every
single voter
should act as if their vote could turn
your state from one candidate to the
other
which is to overwhelm the vote to such a
degree
that none of these bamboozlings and lies
actually help
donald trump to get reelected i was born
in argentina
[Music]
what we have to make sure we do is to
vote participate keep the pressure on as
far as the post office keep the pressure
on as far as
vote by mail and fundamentally the
question is do you want to remove
trump enough that you will vote for joe
biden
it's going to be a turnout battle and
specifically it'll be turn out in key
states
which will decide who wins it's
convalescent plasma
crawl over broken glass to vote in
november
so my ethnicity is ashkenazi jewish our
focus needs to be
getting out the vote and making sure
that we vote
authorization for a treatment known as
convalescent plasma
a wide array of effective treatments
including a powerful antibody treatment
known as convalescent plasma i i know
you guys are
too smart but why would we take any
chance
crawl over broken glass to vote in
november
and insane possibly illegal
certainly immoral listen i'm sick of
this trust
nothing other than your ability to vote
and to convince others to vote that's it
[Music]
yeah i like it
[Music]
if our turnout is low it could hand the
election to donald trump
if our turnout is high it will not make
a difference if we
overwhelm the vote and that includes
when you can safely vote in person
doing it when you can vote by mail
sending in your ballot two
three four weeks early meaning if it
takes an extra five days to be delivered
it's not going to be
a problem these techniques
cannot put trump back in the oval office
if
if if if we vote okay now this
is sort of funny but some people are
furious